- So you said something else that
I literally read this
article and I was like,
"Oh my God, you're in my head."
- Really?
- Because you said you'll
never get married again.
I will never get married again.
Not because I don't believe in love.
- I know, I know, I'm
saying I believe in love.
- I think love is beautiful
and it's not that I just did not,
that didn't suit me.
- Yeah.
- And yeah, in my life.
And so I thought it was
awesome that you address that.
Not many people address, cause I feel like
where I'm from, you have to like,
there's steps you have to
- Of course, of course.
- And it's just exhausting,
cause it doesn't work
in everyone's life like that.
- Not in this, and not the way we work.
I feel like there's, we're just
a different type of person.
I want a relationship.
- Me too.
- I can't wait to have
a partner that I adore
and I hope that's there for me.
But as far as, I don't
know the marriage thing
I just apparently I'm not great at.
- No
- And I'm accepting my you know
- It's a hard thing to do.
- Shortcomings, yes.
- Especially cause a
lot of us get together,
like I don't know about y'all but,
like from where I'm from once again
and I am like, I was old at 30
to even meet someone and
then get right at 31.
- Right, right.
- That was like old.
I was almost dead where I'm from.
Like, you know? Girls are getting
married like 20, you know?
- No, that is scary.
- So it was like, I think.
- That is scary.
- But once you develop those patterns
in your life and it's worked,
it's hard to include another person.
- It's hard.
- I'm like 40 years old.
- It's like hard like to do that.
So anyway, I thought it was awesome.
- And we love our job so much too.
- I love my job.
- I talked a lot about
that in the article too.
Like trying to find some balance now
which I feel like I never did.
Like, it was like one
track mine work career.
- I know.
- I'm learning to find
the, I think I said it.
I'm learning to find the gray.
- Yeah.
- I'm very black and white.
My personality is black and white.
- Yeah.
- How I go about things
and I'm trying to find
some balance cause I've
never had that before.
- I don't know if we
should be real good friends
cause I don't think we'd
be good for each other.
- Cause we are exactly the same.
Am I speaking your language right now?
- Yeah, I'm like, that is so hard for me.
- It's hard.
- No, it's either in or
out it's this or that.
- I know.
- And it's very hard for
me, cause then I feel like
I'm just being apathetic in the middle.
- Me too.
- Like I'm like what?. Anyway.
- And I don't like the middle road.
- Me neither.
- I'm like one or the other, but I have to
I have to balance it out.
- It's healthy, it's
healthy. No, I did too.
I started saying no a lot.